on the mathematics side
what uh if you look back or maybe today
what made you fall in love with
mathematics for me
i think i've always been very attracted
to challenge as i already indicated with
writing the program
i guess if i see something that's hard
or supposed to be impossible
it certain sometimes i say maybe maybe i
want to see if i can pull that off
and with the mathematics the math
competitions presented
problems that were hard that i didn't
know how to start
but for which i could conceivably try to
learn how to solve them
so i mean there are other things that
are hard called like get something to
mars get people to
mars and i didn't i still don't think
that i'm
able to solve that problem on the other
hand the math problems struck me as
things which are
hard and with significant amount of
extra work i could figure it out
and maybe they would actually even be
useful like that that mathematical skill
is the core
of lots of other things
that's really interesting maybe you
could speak to that because
a lot of people say that math is hard
as a kind of negative statement
it always seemed to me a little bit like
that's kind of a positive statement
that all things that are worth having in
this world
are hard i mean everything that people
think about
that they would love to do whether it's
sports
whether it's art music
and all the sciences they're going to be
hard if you want to do something special
so is there something you could say to
that idea that math is hard
should it be made easy or should it be
hard
ah so i think maybe i want to dig in a
little bit onto this hard part
and say uh i think the interesting thing
about the math
is that you can see a question that you
didn't know how to
start doing it before and over a course
of
thinking about it you can come up with a
way
to to solve it and so you can move from
a state of not being able to do
something
to a state of being able to do something
where you
help to take yourself through that
instead of somebody else
spoon feeding you yes that technique so
actually here i'm already digging into
maybe part of my teaching philosophy
also which is that
i actually don't want to ever just tell
somebody
here's how you do something i actually
prefer to say here's an interesting
question
i know you don't quite know how to do it
do you have any ideas
this is i'm actually coming up with i'm
actually explaining another way that you
could try to do teaching
and i'm contrasting this to a method of
watch me do this
now practice it 20 times i'm trying to
say a lot of people
consider math to be hard because maybe
they can't remember
all of the methods that were taught but
for me
i look at the hardness and i don't think
of it as a memory hardness
i think of it as a can you invent
something hardness
and i think that if we can teach more
people how to do that
art of invention in a pure cognitive way
not as hard as the
actual hardware stuff right but like in
terms of the concepts and the thoughts
and the mathematics
teaching people how to invent then
suddenly
actually they might not even find math
to be that
tiresomeness hard anymore but that
rewardingness hard of
i have the capability of looking at
something which i don't know what to do
and coming up with how to do it i
actually think we should be doing that
giving giving people that capability
so hard in the same way that invention
is hard
that is ultimately rewarding so maybe
you can dig in
that a little bit longer which is um
do you see basically the way to teach
math is to present the problem
and to give a person a chance to try to
invent a solution
without with minimal amount of
information first
is that is is that basically how do you
build that muscle of invention
in a student yes so the way that i i
guess i have
two different sort of ways that i try to
teach actually one of them is
in fact this semester because all my
classes were remotely delivered i even
threw them all onto my youtube channel
so you can see
you can see how i teach at carnegie
mellon but i'd often say
hey everyone let's try to do this any
ideas
and that actually changes my role as a
professor
from a person who shows up for class
with a script
of what i want to talk through i
actually i don't have a script the way i
show up for class is
there's something that we want to learn
how to do and we're going to do it by
improv i'm talking about the same method
as improv comedy
which is where you tell me some ideas
and i'll try to yes and them
you know what i mean and then together
we're going to come up with a proof
of this concept where you were deeply
involved
in creating the proof actually every
time i teach the class we do every proof
slightly differently
because it's based on how the students
came up with it
and that's how i do it when i'm in
person i also have another line of
courses that we make that is delivered
online
those things are where i can't do it
live but
the teaching method became also similar
it was just here's an interesting
question
i know it's out of reach why don't you
think about it and then automatic hints
we feed automatically hints
through you know through the internet to
go and let the person
try to invent so that's like a more
rigorous
prodding of invention
you